[Applause]
so max what did you bring I brought my
laundry your laundry yeah where's
Michael
where's Michaels up here in the blue
what's up man how you doing great job I
get I don't know if you get the I get
lists my my wife gives me less and I
have a pretty big one today so I thought
I think this is I'm so happy to be here
this I'm very exciting yeah I have a lot
to get done
and one day you got to make it happen no
I thought I'd multitask okay okay my
sisters watching right now and she's
gonna hate me for this but every time
folding laundry when they tell their
kids while we're folding laundry we're
folding laundry so I love in our house
where we tell the kids that we're
folding laundry and and we're folding
laundry I love it you just keep folding
man just help her I'm excited help you
fall if I posted those yeah sure okay
just laying right here I am I'm really
even if it's dirty I'm in if I had
posted I'm like I had posted those
pictures online my wife would have been
like yeah and my I know I was like I
love these pictures it's like what like
wives have been doing for centuries it's
fine it's like I always find it I always
find it odd to fold my kids clothes oh
really I love the miniature ones because
they're easier you know what I hate I
put a sheet it's like origami though a
very difficult sheet on fire I literally
just end up doing this I start out so
proud and then I just do this
no yeah I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my YouTube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this